isabelle elle va devoir faire gagner je
vous le dis une magnifique voiture
isabelle ça va être très simple elle va
devoir se garer enfin pas l1 regardez
ben salah qui a gagné à celle qui a
gagné elle est dehors vous allez voir
c'est une voiture décapotable un
cabriolet a gagné ce soir un cabriolet à
gagner dans touche pas à mon poste
isabelle ne sera pas au volant elle sera
à côté d'un moniteur d'auto école qui
aura les yeux bandés il va avoir deux
minutes en écoutant les instructions
d'isabelle pour se garer possible
d'accord je suis à deux minutes pour se
garer regardez on est en train de les
mettre en place
isabelle va être mis en face à l'eire
juste je crois on me dit nous sommes à
boulogne billancourt en région
parisienne et on me dit que la météo est
de plus en plus qu'un mécontents et
voilà il est content alors isabelle
maman d'hommes dans un instant elle va
avoir deux minutes pour se garer je vous
le dis et il ya une famille qui est avec
nous et qui va pouvoir gagner donc ce
magnifique cette magnifique voiture
puisque on a reçu une vidéo qui nous a
tous bouleversés
je vous le dis au bureau c'est la vidéo
de juliette elle m'a expliqué qu'en ce
moment les fins de mois étaient
difficiles et qu'une de ses filles
souffrait de handicap parce que tu es
pmp aussi c'est beaucoup de ce qu'on
appelle de régalade parce qu'on a envie
de vous aider au quotidien et je vais
pas vous mentir
elle a dû elle voulait roues voilà
revendre sabres étaient des culées sa
voiture pour les cadeaux de noël et ça
nous a foutu une grosse sera sera
regardé coup bah moi je m'appelle à nos
âges et 12 ans
coucou je m'appelle siagi ça qu on
voulait te dire que notre maman c'est la
meilleure la main du monde elle fait
beaucoup de choses pour nous elle a même
vendu sa voiture à noël pour nous faire
avec
oh voilà et si ce serait possible que tu
fasses un petit cadeau à son tour aux
gros bisous j'étais contiennent alors je
crois que la famille de juliette est là
est ce qu'on peut avoir la famille de
juliette avec nous qui va voir si
isabelle va réussir ce défi de garer la
voiture
isabelle avec un prof d'auto école
est-ce qu'ils sont là je crois que da
silva venait me voir voler les déboires
alors et il va avoir donc cette voiture
que vous voyez donc qui va être à gagner
est ce qu'on peut avoir le duplex voilà
regardez donc attention je vous le dis
ils sont prêts en tout cas venez venez
venez me voir comment ça va très bien
alors merci d'être là quand servat
mecheri coin tu t'appelles à noah quand
il avait saisi tout un gros bisous à toi
ô mânes merci d'être là alors je sais
que c'est un peu difficile en ce moment
que vous avez absolument besoin d'une
voiture c'est pas faux alors on va
espérer qu isabelle pour isabelle ça se
passe bien les enfants vous allez
encourager isabelle elle était avec un
prof d'auto-école chevronnés isabelle
elle va avoir deux minutes pour donner
des indications à ce professeur de école
pour qu'ils puissent bien se garer est
ce qu'on peut voir la place dans
laquelle il doit se garer s'il vous
plaît voilà voyez doit vraiment être
dans les tuyaux
s'il n'est pas dans les plots s'est
perdu chez eux
voyez d'art opus est vieille comme il
est il est mal placé pour l'instant et
comme je voulais dit la météo est un
petit peu capricieuse attention est-ce
que vous êtes prêts là bas est ce que
vous n'êtes pas isabelle c'est nous la
place il chérit ciel c'est pour les
corbeaux
on sait jamais il peut pleuvoir à tout
moment quand vous êtes en cabriolet
comment il s'appelle votre professeur
d'auto école il s'appelle greg ça va il
est gentil
pour l'instant oui mais à mon avis c'est
un vide se gâter alors isabelle ma
chérie vous allez devoir guide et greg
dans les plots pour qu'on puisse se
garer d'accord isabelle mais les plots
mais bon tout est permis toujours bah
oui c'est que vous avez pas de permis
mais c'est lui qui conduit il a les yeux
bandés plus rien isabelle il a les yeux
bandés
c'est vous qui allez me guider j'avais
les yeux bandés d'accord voilà ça qui
borde a pour l'instant les abeilles
chalmé ben oui la belle isabelle
attention on va partir pour deux minutes
il a donné pour se garer il s'appelle
arrête partir j'ai un truc à vous dire
vous êtes en cabriolet vous attend
cabriolet mais la météo en 2001 est très
capricieuse
il a dit que la météo était très
capricieuse en europe et en asie du masi
[Rires]
[Musique]
l'accouchement a indiqué migration de
moi qui m'arrivait
[Rires]
la belle isabelle isabelle est ce qu'on
attendait isabelle est ce que vous
m'entendez isabelle à ce que tu
m'entends isabelle s'est perdu alors
arrêtez toiture en mettait la voiture
arrêter la voiture arrêtée thoirette le
jeu d'eau en fait arrêter le massacre
periph les chérit les cherry on se calme
isabelle est ce que tu m'as pas rassuré
c'est pas bien de jurés l'ont mis là
j'ai vraiment pas bien
nathalie croisé dans notre mariage
jamais c'est perdu j'ai perdu des à bâle
c'est pas ça ça de ma mère on peut dire
qu'à ma vie
[Applaudissements]
et me voler ma chérie mecheri
malheureusement la voiture et perdu la
voiture et perdu je suis désolé à côté à
cause isabelle mais heureusement on
avait quand même un 4-4-1-1 véhicules
qui étaient dans le hall magnifique et à
vous c'est pour eux
[Applaudissements]
non merci
c'est pour vous monsieur
merci
merci les chéris merci merci cette
voiture cette voiture elle est à vous et
on peut remercier le constructeur ça
commence par un gars et ça et et les
chéris comme je sais que c'est très dur
pour nous en ce moment
et mine de rien une voiture et en ce
moment on sait comme l'essence coûte
cher je rajoute un an de carburant pour
vous voilà
[Applaudissements]
et on merci la marque commence par un à
des ratonnades est reconnu la voiture
elle est magnifique c'est pour vous
je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en course en championnat
romain
[Musique]
et
bon match comme ça
abbas continue émission comme ça ça va
me suis tu veux voter des missions avec
moi tu vas rester un petit peu comme ça
avec moi bon on va très bien écrit